お忙しい中ありがとうございます
予定の時間は過ぎておりますが
何かご質問などございましたら挙手いただけますでしょうか
じゃあマイクを回します
もう一回挙手していただけますか？じゃあ先に
住者の件の後は あんなの村人が招かれたところにお釈迦様もついてくるようなっていう
あの理由は  なるほど それでアナンジャ村に今自分がお世話する人だから
どちらに行くべきかと決める権利がありますから
今の現代社会でも同じことで
例えば総理大臣誰になるのかという
その責任の公務員の人がいるんですよ
例えば天皇陛下の場合でも
宮内庁で決めるでしょ
どこに行くべきかと だから皇室の方々は
我々をどこかに呼んでほしい
来ていただきたい場合は
我々は直接天皇陛下に言わないんですね
皇太子に言わないで宮内庁に報告するんです
宮内庁がOKを受けて報告すると
何のことなく来ていただくんですよ
だから宮内庁の人々はお世話係ばっかりなんですけど
そういう権利があるんです
そのようにアナンダ尊者がもうこの人のところでお釈迦様がいて説法した方がいいと思ったらもう言うんです
私は接待を受けましたけど
お釈迦様も一緒に来てくださいと
そういう授者の権利なんですね
えっと アナンダ尊者がお釈迦様が授業についてお話しなされた時に
なぜ止めなかったのかという疑問なんですけど
授業を延ばしてくださいと指示しなかったことは
それって疑問 仏教の世界でも疑問がありまして
注釈書はこのアナンダ尊者心のマーラさんが入って
頭がしっかり動かないようにしたという話があります
それはちょこっと神秘的な話で
気づかなかったというだけのことなんですね
しかし お釈迦様の言葉が言葉を読んでも
私たちもそう気にならないんですよ
後からわかってももう遅いんです
私は子供の頃 ずいぶん子供の頃
ずっと読んでいて 気づかなかったんです
ウェーサーリ美しい 私は四人息育てているんだから
まあその気になればもう長生きできますよとか言ったりしていて
どんな脈絡でしょうかとかね
ウェーサーラ美しいとこれと合わないでしょうに
言葉が 普通明確に語るのに
そこでちょっとわからないというか
微妙な そこでマーラが出てきて
もう早く涅槃に入ってくださいと言ったところで
あ しまった 私も思ったんです
あ しまったね あの言葉はその意味でしたのかと
なんてもったいないことでしょうかと思った
子供頃はね あるんですよ
今はそう思わないんだけど
で なぜかというと お釈迦様はまあその気持ちで語ったんだからね
邪魔するなよと もう結構やと
だからこの前言ったんだからね
ボロ車をなんとか紐でつないでなんとか動かしているような感じで
自分の体はなんとか動かしているだけですと
あの 6年の苦行っていうのは恐ろしいもんだから
80歳までいたことも奇跡なんですよ
恐ろしい苦行をしたんだからね
体も 3回ももう死にかけだったしね
だからそれは結構効いたんでしょうね
年取れば取るほど それで胃腸がね
すごく弱かったし だから 1日でもいることは
お釈迦様にとってはものすごい苦しみでしたと思いますよ
肉体的な苦しみがね 体の痛みはね
耐え難かったと思います
でも先生がそれを表現していないんです
だからまあ気持ちよく涅槃に入れたかったでしょうね
そういうことだから ちょっと微妙にわかる
しかし 言っておかなきゃ自分の責任逃れになりますから
一応 3回ぐらいは派手に
私は派手に言ったんだよと
品のない言葉で言ったんだよと言うんですね
でもその時あなたは気づかなかったんだというふうになっていますけどね
だからこれは最後のところだから
このちょっと学者もね
後で書いたものを作ったものはないんではないかと思ったりもするし
私もそう可能性もあるし
それからアーナンダ尊者第三結集でアーナンダ尊者に懺悔しなさいとすごい訴えられたんですよ
アーナンダ最初に訴えられたのはこの第三第一結集の時なんですよ
お坊さんたちがね あなたのせいでお釈迦様が早く涅槃に入られたと
あなたの責任だよと すごい厳しく
だからお釈迦様がいる間はアーナンダ尊者立場良かったんですけど
涅槃に入られたらもう本当に立場がなくなっちゃったんです
助けてくれたのはカッサパ尊者なんです
ずっと叱っていたんですけど
やっぱり宝物っていうことで
カッサパ尊者が守ってあげたんですけど
アーナンダ尊者はもう私は有罪じゃないんだと
で そこはわからなかった
それでもサンガは私の誤りやと思うならば
私は謝りますと もう一つは
このお釈迦様の体を女性になんで見せたんですかと
偉大なる如来の体をね
亡くなったらね アーナンダ尊者はずっと女性たちにはい
そばに入って見て見て拝んでくださいと
言ったら 女性たちが泣きながら髪の毛こうしながら
ギャーギャーと来て泣きながらお釈迦様の体を触ったりして
もう出ていかない はい
次の方 次の方と言わなくちゃいけなかったんです
男性の方々はすごい丁寧に
偉大なお釈迦様だからね
もう礼拝をするだけで
女たちは何のことなくそこで泣き崩れちゃうと
それでお釈迦様の体で女性たちの涙やら唾液やら
それで汚れちゃったんだと
それあんた方あんたやったんだと
ブッダの体触らせたことが女性に
女性は触ってはいけないんだからね
出家は それで逆にあの出家
女性にも男性の体触ってはいけないんです
どちらでも同じですけど
アーナンダ尊者はもうそれ気にしなかった
涅槃に入られたんだから
女性たちにもやっぱり平等に
ブッダにももう死体になっている
その時だけでもという気持ちでしたからね
だからあなたが間違いだと懺悔しなさいと
言われたら まあ私はまあ別な気持ちで良いことだと思ってやったことですが
まあ私の間違いというならば謝りますということで懺悔するんですけど
そういうことでね もう結構トラブルは後で起きましたよ
だからなぜお釈迦様に言わなかったのかっていうことは微妙にわからない
だから私の個人的な判断は
あの言葉を私が読んだ時でも
私には読み取れなかったんです
お釈迦様はアーナンダ尊者にお願いが立てるまで待ってるんだと
だから仏教の世界っていうのは
このお願いしたらやるというね
例えば我々は人にお経をあげて祝福はしないんですけど
禁止です しかし 言われたらやるんです
で 私は病気で倒れちゃって
なんとか祝福してくださいと言ったら
さっさと行くんです 問題なく文句なく
まあずっと仲良くしている信者さんの場合は勝手にしてもOKなんですけど
そうでないと 向こうは頼むまで待つんですよ
そういうことだから お釈迦様は頼むまで待っていたんだというね
ことは読めなかったこと
ですから 私にも読み取れなかったし
あの言葉ではね で これでも私はすごい厳しく物事を分析する性格でしょうしね
アーナンダ尊者にしても同じことでしたんじゃないかなと
読めなかったのは 我々は私の頭悪いのはいいんだけど
アーナンダ尊者の頭悪いわけではなくて
もっと智慧完成した人がそういうことをからくりやっているんだからではないんですかね
だからそれはあくまでもお釈迦様がそう決めたんだからなんです
もう早く涅槃に入りたいと
お釈迦様の智慧にはもう勝てっこはないんだから
読み取れないようにすると思ったら読み取れないんです
もうお手上げなんです
現代人も後の話で頭を汚さないで
初めから読んでみると同じことなんです
学者のくだらない本をいろいろ読んだりして
頭汚れてるでしょうね
私は学者の本を読む前に
以前物語読む時とし読んでみたんだから
その時読み取らなかったんです
ということです  えっと
他にご質問あったりしますか
はい えっと あの お釈迦様が食事のオファーを受けた時に
アーナンダ尊者はついていかないという禁止事項で
ちょっと聞き取れない
お釈迦様が食事のお布施に招待された時に
アーナンダ尊者はついて行きませんというのがあったんですけども
条件としてアーナンダ尊者がいつもそばにいるということと
それはちょっとやっぱ無視してて
お釈迦様一人で行かれた場合
何かあったらどうするのかなというの思ったんですけど
ああ それは気をつけるでしょう
おそらくアーナンダ尊者が
何かあったっていったって別に何もないし
もう心配ないしね まあ食事いただくために托鉢するのは毎日のことでしょ
托鉢に行く場合は一緒に行くんです
誰から関係なくいただく
大体はお釈迦様は微妙に一人にするんで
その時も なぜかというと
このお釈迦様が来たということで
みんなお布施するんですよ
だからそのお釈迦様の徳で誰もお布施いただきたくないんです
だから微妙にすれるんです
それで行くんです 一人一人で行くんです
托鉢は  だからそこら辺はあんまり問題起こらないと思います
托鉢の場合はみんなで一緒に出て
それぞれ別々に道を歩くんです
だって十人五人グループでいけば
在家の方々に結構厳しいでしょう
貧しい人々の方 特に行くんだからね
だからひとさじしかくれないし
このひとさじしかない場合は
三人行ったらね 誰にあげるかなって問題も出てくるし
あるいは誰かがお釈迦様がいらっしゃったら
この食べ物をお釈迦様にあげたいと思ったもので
アーナンダ尊者と一緒に行けたら
半分お釈迦様 半分アーナンダ尊者になるでしょうに
それもやりたくはないしね
それで托鉢の場合は 誰が来るかと信者さんには知ることはできないんです
ある人が自分の家で料理を用意して
わざとお釈迦様にお布施する
そうしたらお釈迦様が来るか来ないかわからないんですからね
そこはいつでも未確定にするんです
信者さんもただ仏法僧にお布施をする
何々さんとはないという
信者さんの徳が無料になるような計画なんです
だから前もって言わない
今日はサーリプッタ尊者方が托鉢に行くんだと
この町はとかね 言ったらとんでもない仏教違反なんです
そうするとみんな待ち構えているんだから
準備して それはしなかったんです
今の大導化メンバーと同じことですよ
誰が来るか 信者さんはもう関係ない
わからない ただ お布施を用意してサンガに差し上げたいと待っているだけ
というわけで あのー 我々は顔を隠せませんだけど
禅寺だったらね 大きな帽子で顔まで隠せますけどね
そこまでやらなくても
もう向こうは頭いいんだからね
みんな信者さんがよく知ってます
何々お坊さんとは思わない
そのお布施するときは思わないんですよ
あれすごい不思議なんです
普通は何々さん 何々さんとよくよく個人的にやりとりやりますけど
法事の時はもうきれいさっぱりそれ消すんです
信者さん頭から これは法事ですと
サンガにやってるんだと
そういうことですからね
お釈迦様が受けた接待はお釈迦様がアイコンです
と言われても 在家の方は
お釈迦様と比丘たちにお布施しますと言ったら行くんです
それは在家の信者さんの責任です
だから経典を読むと あの
スワートナーやバッタンなんとか何とかですけど
あのブッダンチャビックスサンガンチャという風にお願いする場合あるでしょ
経典にあるんですよ そういう文章はたくさん
その場合はブッダと比丘たちにお布施したいと
いう場合は お釈迦様は受けるんだ
お釈迦様にお願いを立てるんだから
その場合 比丘たちは行く義務が生じています
お釈迦様がお受けしたのは自分と比丘たちのためだから
お釈迦様がした約束のには断りますと
これはできません 逆に在家の方がそういうケースはないんだけど
明日自分の家にお釈迦様とアナンダ尊者が来てほしいと言ったら
お釈迦様はもう起きたらもうアナンダ尊者行くしかないんです
その場合はアナンダ尊者の接待がお釈迦様がお受けしたんだから
アナンダ尊者にもう断然的に断ることは全く不可能です
お釈迦様にお布施しますと言ったら
もうお釈迦様だけ 他のお坊さんたちも行かない
次ですけども あのアナンダ尊者がどうして女性は議会に出たいしないんですか？と質問した時に
お釈迦様はどういうふうにお答えされたのです
読んでみてください 今日３回あります
もう一つですが あの第1結集の時にアナンダ尊者はどうしてビハラピーという言葉をですね
ビハラピー あの  例えばエーヴァンスさん
エーカンサマヤン様はパラダシアンビハラティ
ビハラピーっていうふうに現在形で使われてるんですけども
あ どうしてその現在形で使われているのか
何か深い意味があるのか
あるいはあのインドの文化とか文学的なものと
これはインド言語の文化なんですね
英語でも歴史は現代現在形で書くんです
全部英語の文章もそういう書き方なんです
それがこの そういうテニスというか文章があるんです
現代形なんですけど 過去にも現在にも将来にも一般のことを喋る場合は現代形なんです
だから経典は我々は今読んでいるもので
だからエワメーソンエカンセメント
過去なんですけど サーワッティアンビハラティというと
読む我々にとっても もう今お釈迦様がいるという感じで
それで生々で頭に入るんです
生で 歴史のテキストを書く場合も
私は英語を勉強した時は過去形使わないでくださいと
それ間違いと使うと 歴史の教科書で何か書けた
これでこの時こう言ってああ言ってこうこうなるという
これ全部あのプレゼントで書くんです
シンプルプレゼント英語で言うんです
これパーリ語でもシンプルプレゼントなんで
それでも必要な時はちゃんとあります
まあ深い意味があるかどうかでしょうかな
あんまりもうあまり気にしないというかね
だからあれはこのヴィーラティって言えば
私はヴィーラで正しいと感じますよ
ヴィーラシンでしちゃうと成り立たなくなってですよ
ストーリーが だからヴィーラティ住んでいた
その時がこういうことが起きたということですから
次は過去形になります
例えばマングルスッタから言えば
沢辺でジェトナビニがサラメ
あとアニャタラデワタビカンダラビカンタワナゲラカッパンジェトナバセッタ
イエナバガワテーヌウパサンカメと過去形なんです
それは過去でいいんです
その出来事をこと起きてる間でも
お釈迦様はずっと住むスッスですからね
お釈迦様の場合は現代シンプルプレゼントになっちゃうんです
ヴィーラティと その時お釈迦様は答えました
アッジャバシと過去形なんです
それから経典になってくると
また普遍的な動詞になるんです
シンプルになるんです
お釈迦様の実際の言葉は全部現在形です
か 時間を飛んだ抜いた言葉になるんです
一応すべてブッダの言葉そのものも現在形です
例えばエーサダンモーサナンタノという場合は動詞がないんだけど
動詞が隠れているでしょ
これは普遍的な真理であるなんです
ありましたと言っちゃうとおかしいでしょ
普遍的な真理にあるだろうともおかしいでしょ
だからエーサダンモーサナンタノの場合はエーサダンモーサナンタノホーティなんですね
動詞は使ってないんだけど
方針はダメです 必須でもダメです
ホーティなんです でないと文法間違いです
そんなところやと思います
最後に田んぼの形っていうのは四角いっていうんですか
あの衣ですね  まあ四角長方形だから
あの田んぼのあの間歩く道ありますね
えっ？何道 汗道 それがまっすぐ一つあって
こうやって横にあるんですね
十字になりません 田んぼの場合は
日本の田んぼも同じだと思います
十字になりません まっすぐあって
こちらこちら 1つあると
次の横の道はこちらになるんですね
こういう風には作らないんですね
だから十字架はないんです
ありがとうございます
ちょっと専門的な質問でしたけど
他にもう少し素朴なものが質問ございましたら
はい  すいません あの ブッダから学んだ 5つのタイトルのうちですね
正確者大地ということで
他人の気持ちに逆らわないということと対立しないということがありまして
あと 勇敢大地というのは優柔不断の反対で決断が強いということなんですけども
俗世間の例えばリーダーをやるときに
この 2つが微妙にこう
項目がこう矛盾しちゃうっていうか
相反しちゃう  それは能力ない人の場合です
能力のあるリーダーが
ものすごい柔軟性を持って自分の道をちゃんと導くんです
例えば リーダーとして命令せねばしなくちゃいけないでしょ
下手なリーダーはこれこれやりなさいと言うんです
上手な能力あるリーダーは
実はこういう問題がありましたので
私はこの場合はこうした方がいいんじゃないという自分が考えていますけど
いかがでしょうかと もちろんどうせリーダーだから
向こうの人々にはそんな案が出ませんね
そしたら それはその通りです
では やりましょう で終わり
だから相手に命令してないんです
かなりこの調和を厚くっちゃうんです
いわゆるやらせるんではなくて
やる気持ちにさせるのはリーダーなんです
やる気持ちになったら自分にしてやってるんです
で 俗世間ではみんな能力があるわけじゃないんだから
そこら辺結構ぶつかったりはしますよ
それは私の管轄外です
一応やり方を教えるだけです
私にと私は  ありがとうございます
はい わかりやすい れば私は皆様に一度命令したことがありますかね
いろいろやらせているでしょうに
他の方よろしいでしょうか
では  はい では終了いたします
祝福の経をあげますので
合掌してください サッビーティオーヴィワンジャントゥ
サッバローゴウィナッサトゥ
マーテーバワットワンタラーヨ
スティーディーガーユコバヴァ
ババトゥサッバマングラントゥ
サッバデヴァタ サッバブッダヌバーヴェーナ
サダースッティバヴァントゥテー
ババトゥサッバマングラントゥ
サッバデヴァタ サッバダンマヌバーヴェーナ
サダースッティバヴァントゥテー
ババトゥサッバマングラントゥ
サッバデヴァタ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ
サダースッティバヴァントゥテー
アビワダナシーリッサ
ニッチャンワッダパチャイノ
チャッターロダンマワッダンティ
アーユワンノスカンバラン
サッバーイサバーイ  ありがとうございます